hu
ce
donc l'objet de ce courrier est très
clair mais le plus important au milieu
de ceux de ce courrier je retrouve une
phrase qui m'a marqué bien que n'ayant
aucune expérience et après plusieurs
tentatives infructueuses
j'ai pris le pari de vous faire cette
surprise pour vous surprendre et attirer
votre attention
entre les lignes je lis pas d'expérience
pas de job alors la fin et plus tôt et
plus heureuse puisque j'ai eu l'occasion
de rencontrer cette personne et nous
avons collaboré quelques années
néanmoins cet événement m'a marqué et il
a servi de fil conducteur à l'ensemble
de ma carrière de recruteurs depuis plus
de 20 ans en effet vous me l'accorderez
dans un monde où on dit que les jeunes
représentent l'avenir du monde
mais l'entreprise aussi est-il vraiment
normal de constater qu'il est plus
difficile pour un jeune de trouver un
emploi que pour ses aînés
il suffit pour s'en convaincre de
regarder le taux de chômage des jeunes
en france est il normal alors que tout
parent qui se respecte et j'en suis un
voit dans l'accomplissement
professionnels une partie de
l'accomplissement personnel de voir des
jeunes au ban du marché de l'emploi
est il normal de voir que londres est
devenue la sixième ville française par
le nombre de jeunes qui trouvent leur
premier emploi qui ne trouvent plus en
france le constat est très claire est ce
une fatalité pour autant
ma réponse est non il existe des
solutions et j'aimerais partager trois
thèmes avec vous le premier thème
recruter autrement
le deuxième thème fort mais autrement
le troisième thème manager autrement
prenons un peu de temps sur le recruter
autrement
depuis des décennies les méthodes de
recrutement n'ont pas changé elle
consiste à repérer des méthodes de
recrutement axé sur les mots clés et à
rechercher des compétences
or historiquement ça se traduisait par
une lettre de motivation un cv qu'ils
reportaient une expérience parfois
longue comme le bras
on très difficile a relaté quand on
sortait de ses études sans expérience
ans on aurait pu imaginer que la
révolution digitale aurait pu résoudre
ce dilemme de là il n'en a rien été et
pourtant souvenez vous c'est
probablement le monde du recrutement qui
était parmi les premiers secteurs
concernés par la révolution digitale
avec l'émergence des jobboards fin des
années 90 mais ces jobs en ont fait
qu'empiler des cv et à nouveau on
fermait le recruteur dans l'idée de
rechercher des mots clés voire mieux de
porter des algorithmes qui amène
toujours à cette logique de compétence
et de mots clés les réseaux sociaux
finalement non fake évoluer dans le même
sens en mettant juste en lumière des
candidatures dite passive
en plus des candidatures active alors
comment fait-on pour sortir d'une
logique de compétence et l est vers une
logique de potentiels ou probablement
les jeunes y trouveront un meilleur
terrain de jeu comment fait-on pour
sortir en à mettre deux méthodes de
recrutement axé sur des normes des
algorithmes et aller vers un recrutement
qu'on dit plus affinitaires
j'ai une très bonne nouvelle les
technologies devrait nous y aider et
commence à nous y aider première
innovation
vous connaissez tous le quotient
intellectuel très longtemps il est resté
roi et il a identifié la capacité de
quelqu'un a résonné délaissant parfois
la capacité de quelqu'un à agir ou
interagir
or vous l'imaginez bien dans un monde
qui évolue à une vitesse incroyable
il est essentiel d'avoir des capacités
d'adaptation et un peu de jeu de jambes
la bonne nouvelle c'est que le quotient
émotionnel devrait rapidement équilibrée
le quotient intellectuel pour le dire
rapidement le quotient émotionnel c'est
la faculté à pouvoir s'adapter à des
situations à des mises en situation a
des relations interpersonnelles et qui
permet également de gérer ses émotions
dans des situations spécifiques comme
par exemple la pression le stress
nécessaire compagnon de changement
extrêmement rapide ce quotient
émotionnel fait l'objet de recherches et
devrait délivrer les premiers outils
d'assessment qui vont enfin remettre au
même niveau caution intellectuelle
quotient émotionnel
deuxième thème la culture d'entreprise
on le dit très peu mais en france 30 %
des recrutements
eshu durant la première année parmi les
personnes en cdi et la raison majeure on
est que les personnes ne s'adaptent pas
nécessairement à la culture d'entreprise
ou au style de management de
l'entreprise
ils seraient de fait une très bonne idée
que de pouvoir anticiper cette capacité
de matching entre une personnalité une
motivation personnelle et la culture de
l'entreprise qui vous accueille
la bonne nouvelle là aussi c'est que les
technologies vont nous aider
le big data fait également son émergence
au sein du monde du recrutement et par
la loi des grands nombres permet
d'anticiper les caractéristiques d'un
candidat donné en termes de personnalité
surtout de motivation au travail et ce
qui réunit dans un même adn l'ensemble
des collaborateurs d'une entreprise
bien sûr ça n'est pas une science exacte
mais ça permet juste de comprendre ce
qui peut transférer les fiançailles qui
sont la période d'essai dans le cadre
d'un contrat de recrutement en mariage
réussi entre un candidat une entreprise
là aussi les technologies ont évolué et
devrait nous aider
j'ai souvent tendance à le dire souvent
dans mon entreprise je suis sûr que les
meilleurs concurrents les meilleurs
collaborateurs de mes concurrents ne
réussiront pas nécessairement dans mon
entreprise
la raison en est simple les compétences
sont là leur personnalité leurs
motivations sont peut-être pas toujours
adaptés à la culture entreprise qui est
celle de notre entreprise
alors bien sûr les technologies ne font
pas tout et sur ce volet recruter
autrement j'aimerais terminer en disant
que la poignée de main la relation
interpersonnelle qui est aussi important
dans un monde professionnel que dans un
monde personnel auront toujours une
place centrale dans cette belle qualité
qu'est la rencontre professionnelle
d'ailleurs à ce titre depuis vingt ans
j'ai une hygiène qui consiste à toujours
voir deux candidats par semaine de façon
à identifier des candidats dix coups de
coeur ou aucun donc bouclé n'est
intervenu dans la collaboration et dans
la mise en relation le recruter
autrement est important je vous le
disais et je voudrais m'attarder
maintenant sur le fort mais autrement
nos parents nous disait passe ton bac es
tu travailleras après nous mêmes en tant
que parents parfois disons passe ton bac
+
5 et après tu travailleras et pourtant
quand vous regardez les statistiques
cette année 38 % des diplômés de bac + 5
sont au chômage un an après être sorti
leurs études
ça signifierait que le diplôme ne fait
pas tout dans la recherche d'emploi sur
cette thématique de la formation
regardons aussi du côté de nos voisins
les pays en europe qui ont les meilleurs
taux d'intégration des jeunes sont les
pays d'europe du nord
l'allemagne et la suisse en suisse on ne
regarde pas la proportion d'une
population qui passe son bac on regarde
le nombre d'actes de nombre de personnes
qui suivent un parcours d'alternance
plus de 70 % des diplômés le sont suite
à une alternance en allemagne qui compte
trois fois plus d'alternants qu'en
france les alternants suivent un
parcours pour vous pendant plus de
trente mois
quand ce parcours dure 17 mois en france
et force est de constater que le taux de
chômage des jeunes est au même niveau
que le taux de chômage des personnes qui
ont déjà une certaine séniorité ce sera
un exemple réussi en france
l'objectif est de former autrement
d'éviter ce dilemme de devoir former
pour ensuite travailler et l'alternance
est probablement une solution pour le
former autrement considérant qu'
aujourd'hui quatre cent mille emplois ne
sont pas pourvus en france il faudrait
appeler une expérience professionnelle
plutôt dans le parcours qui permet de
comprendre quel comportement adopter
dans une entreprise
comment également mettre à profit
l'ensemble de ce que l'on apprend sur
les bancs de l'école dans l'entreprise
avec une appropriation immédiate et pas
quelques années après mais le fort mais
autrement c'est aussi la technologie
on le sait les jeunes sont très féru de
digital et de solutions à distance la
première innovation pédagogique a été le
e-learning maintenant probablement un
peu dépassée mais qui a permis de faire
la formation distant ciel une autre
actuelle ce sont les boucs qui ont cet
objectif de faire en sorte que tout ce
qui est matière
précise littéraire est a pris avant la
séance collaborative au sein de l'école
et cette séance loin d'être le fait d'un
professeur au milieu d'une salle entre
quatre murs avec un tableau déversant
une pédagogie descendante est plutôt le
fait d'une pagaie pédagogique
collaborative avec l'idée notamment de
l'émergence du virtual learning tiers
cette idée d'avoir un professeur un
chercheur qui s'adresse à une communauté
de personnes un peu partout dans le
monde sur leurs choix et qui participe à
l'appropriation du programme pédagogique
et dans le monde de l'entreprise cela se
traduit également par ce qu'on appelle
les serious games c'est à dire
l'objectif de pouvoir jouer de façon à
s'approprier un contenu dans un
environnement collaboratif participatif
avec un plaisir à l'enseignement
beaucoup plus important se former
autrement est une clé se recruter
autrement est une clé mais ça ne serait
rien s'il n'y avait pas le manager
autrement manager autrement c'est la
capacité qui ont maintenant les
entreprises et les managers formés sur
les bancs de l'école de pouvoir manager
trois générations dans une même
entreprise
avec l'allongement de la vie
professionnelle c'est la capacité à
manager le multiculturel avec une mixité
de plus en plus importante à l'école
c'est la capacité à gérer dans un même
projet des personnes en cdi mais aussi
des freelances des sous traitants des
intérimaires c'est la capacité à gérer
tous ces formats là mais avant toute
chose je voudrais conclure en vous
disant que c'est aussi la capacité à
donner à identifier la qualité d'un
projet à donner du sens à du progrès ce
projet et enfin de faire confiance aux
jeunes et les entreprises ne seront pas
déçus merci